chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett joins us now from our Washington
bureau with more on this story major
good morning we just heard Nancy Pelosi
called this letter really sick a lot of
people are stunned by it did the people
inside the White House know he was going
to write it and what are they saying
about it today
well sure the President ordered up and
he has sent it he owns it it's now part
of his rhetoric dealing with impeachment
so the president's completely satisfied
but there were division scale within the
White House there were some who said mr.
president look riot accomplishments from
last week on trade defense spending even
family medical leave be above this
process if you can the president
couldn't he wanted to get down and dirty
in the process he wanted to leave sort
of a torched scorched earth rhetoric in
the appeasement record in his own voice
and he has quite clearly done that what
does he think this is gonna mean for his
legacy impeachment itself is a mark on
president Trump's legacy a negative one
he knows it he didn't anticipate it Gail
when the president overruled some of his
advisors many months ago and said Nolet
released the transcript of the call he
thought that that act would prevent this
day from happening
that it hasn't suggest to him in one
small way that he miscalculated about
the importance of releasing that
transcript he thought that might be his
way out it has not proved to be that way
and that bothers him intensely major we
know of two Democrats who say they'll
vote against impeachment is the White
House expecting any more defections it
was last week it isn't anymore
they were confident and I would say
overconfident predictions from House
Republicans and White House folks I
talked to you last week for maybe eight
maybe even ten house defections on the
Democratic side they no longer
anticipate that two to four is the sort
of bandwidth that will still give the
president a shading of bipartisan
opposition to impeachment but not nearly
as many defections as the White House
thought it was generating by its very
strong aggressive political pushback
jumping ahead to a trial Mitch McConnell
says there will be no witnesses is the
White House on board with that strategy
there have been some back-and-forth it
is on board with that strategy and it
creates an enormous gap of credibility
in what the White House had said for so
many weeks it has to be noted the White
House said the house process is
illegitimate the Senate process will be
real that's
we're witnesses and real exculpatory or
defensive evidence for the president
will be submitted now the White House
doesn't appear interested in that
Democrats will reasonably ask why all
right major thank you very much